(logo whooshing)
(mouse clicking)
(electronic chiming)
(pulsating electronic music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Eugenie C. Scott
who is the founding executive director
of the National Center
for Science Education.
She is a past president
of the American Association
of Physical Anthropologists.
Among her most notable recent honors,
the Public Service Medal
of the National Academy of Sciences,
the Fellows Medal of the
California Academy of Sciences,
and the first Stephen Jay Gould Prize,
Society for the Study of Evolution.
Scott is the author of
Evolution Versus Creationism
and co-editor with Glen Branch
of Not in Our Classrooms:
Why Intelligent Design
is Wrong for Our Schools.
Eugenie, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- La Crosse, Wisconsin,
and I was born there
but we kind of bounced between La Cross,
Minneapolis, and Milwaukee.
- And looking back,
did your parents shape your
thinking about the world?
- Hardly at all, (laughs)
because my father left my mother
when I was about four years old or so.
I really don't have any
memory of him living with us.
He was somebody who
visited on odd occasions.
My mother had four kids
and she was kinda running
pretty hard most of the time
just kinda keeping up
with us and the world.
I think I got interested in science
despite my family upbringing
more than anything else.
- And what about religion, was
religion a part of your life?
- My mother was Christian Science
and initially we went to the
Christian Science church.
I remember the Sunday school
being terribly, terribly boring
because they'd give us a Bible,
this is the worst Sunday
school approach ever,
and the kids who could read
would go through the columns on the page
counting the number of times
the word love occurred.
No wonder people leave churches.
I mean, that was just terrible.
When I was probably, I don't know,
maybe seven, eight, nine years old or so,
my older sister decided
that Christian Science
wasn't really where it was at
so she took us to the
Congregational church
in our neighborhood
and I enjoyed attending the
Congregational church very much.
Now it's called the
United Church of Christ,
but that's the historical name for it.
I sang in the choir,
remained in the church
through high school.
- And was it school then
that drew you into science?
And when did science spark for you?
- I think I just, I was
always interested in nature,
and I think that's the way a
lot of people get into science.
They are interested in animals or bugs
or stars or dirt or something like that,
and I remember as a
fourth-grade kid in Minneapolis,
living there at the time,
there was a vacant lot
at the end of our block
and now it's got an
apartment building on it
but at the time it was a vacant lot,
and I would go there and
I would lie in the dirt
and the grass and I
would look for creatures
and just smell the sounds
and listen to the birds
and I was just very, very happy
to just be immersed in that kind of tiny,
I called it my miniature Serengeti.
This was my tiny little
refuge from the busy city
and the streets and
the cars and the noise.
- And when were you drawn to anthropology?
Was it as an undergraduate
or a graduate student?
- Before that, actually.
My, (laughs)
I suppose I shouldn't
really tell this story
about my older sister,
but my older sister,
one of my older sisters was attending
the University of Minnesota
and she brought home her textbooks
and she was taking a course
in anthropology, and yeah,
then as now, I was pretty
much of a compulsive reader.
I must have been probably
in sixth or seventh grade,
sixth grade maybe.
And I started looking through
this book called Anthropology.
I didn't know what anthropology was,
and I came to the human evolution section,
and there were these, and
I know what they are now,
of course, as a professional,
but they were the old
Smithsonian Institution
reconstructions from, like,
the turn of the century,
of Cro-Magnon and
Neanderthal and Homo erectus,
and I looked at these, whoa!
It was just, this was
just the most, who are,
what is this, what's this?
And she said, well, that's
called anthropology.
Okay, I wanna be an anthropologist
because these are our ancestors
and I actually said at the time,
this kinda looks like your boyfriend
and she didn't like that
at all, but nonetheless,
I got inspired by looking
at a college textbook
when I was in about sixth grade.
Then in seventh grade,
my junior high teacher,
middle school teacher, assigned us,
and by that time we
had moved to Milwaukee,
he assigned us a term paper, as it were,
that we had to write a
biography of a famous scientist
which was a really boring
topic, but nonetheless,
that's what they did back then.
And so I decided to do a
term paper on Eugene Dubois
who was the discoverer
of Homo erectus, which,
my teacher had never heard
of Eugene Dubois at all.
He didn't know what Homo erectus was
and I think I got an A on the paper
'cause he had no idea
what I was talking about,
but I had to go to the public library
and find these references
on human evolution
which were way above my reading level,
'cause they were all college-level stuff,
but I would love to have
had that paper now (laughs)
to see what I had extracted from those.
- So it was natural for you
to major in anthropology
and then do your dissertation on that.
- Absolutely.
- And where did you do
your dissertation and who was your mentor?
- I did my master's at UW Milwaukee,
my bachelor's and my master's
there, and then came out,
moved out to California
with my first husband
and he was an anthropology
professor, actually,
and worked out here for a
while with a master's degree.
That was in the late '60s
when you could do that.
You could teach at the college
level with a, you know,
the soldiers were coming back from the war
and there was a real need
for college professors,
so I was able to teach
at the university level
with a master's degree, and I loved it.
I really, really liked
explaining evolution
and anthropology to students
who were only a couple
years younger than I was,
but nonetheless, and so I just said,
I really have to get a graduate degree,
I really have to get a PhD.
So one of my professors
from UWM had subsequently,
and had a few years there,
had moved to the University of
Missouri and I thought, well,
I still have more to learn from
him and he treated me fairly
so I went and got my PhD at
the University of Missouri.
- [Harry] And what was
your dissertation on?
- Bones and teeth. (laughs)
I had gone to Peru to work with a series
of archeologically excavated
skeletal materials,
which was a really great series
of South American, Native American remains
because they were all
radiometrically dated.
We knew what time period
these bodies had come from,
and we also knew from the
archeological information
what their subsistence, food
supply, et cetera, had been
so I had a string of skeletons
that went from very early
hunting and gatherer
through various intermediate
forms of food production
to full corn, bean, squash,
Inca food production,
and what happens to their teeth
and their cranial facial structure
when you make those kinds
of changes and diet.
So it was an interesting topic,
although the sample was really small
and so I don't think anybody
is actually looking up
that dissertation for great enlightenment,
but I basically found things
that people have found subsequently.
- How do you account for your movement
from physical anthropology
to advocacy and activism?
Interestingly enough, focused
on the first instance on evolution.
- Well, you know, it's
an interesting thing.
(sighs) At the time,
when I started teaching
after I got my PhD, that was in 1974
at the University of
Kentucky, and at the time,
it's changed fortunately since then,
but at the time, if you
wanted to study evolution,
the place that you were
guaranteed to get evolution
was in the anthropology department.
I would teach a service
course, as we called them,
and it was a great service course
because if you were a social
studies or humanities major,
you could take my biological anthro class
for social science credit.
If you were a science major,
you could take it for science credit,
or vice versa if you needed to (laughs)
fulfill some university requirement.
So I had all kinds of people
in my introductory physical
anthropology class,
and I would have these biology
majors who were seniors
who just needed to kinda tidy
up their class requirements
so that they could graduate, so, oh well,
this sounds kinda like science.
Let's take that and
we'll check off the box
for social studies.
And of course they found
that it was a whole lot more science
than they thought it
was, but there you go.
And at the end of this
semester, I would have,
'cause basically we got
evolution from day one,
and at the end of the semester,
I would have students come up
to me and say, so that's it.
(both laughing)
Because over in the biology
department in the mid 1970s,
they really weren't being explicit
about common ancestry explains
everything in biology.
We would talk about taxonomy,
the Linnaean system,
and kingdom, phylum, class,
order, genus, and species,
and I just once mentioned
to my students and said, oh,
and the reason why we can group animals
in this hierarchical fashion,
we can group species into genera,
genera into families, et cetera,
is because evolution generates hierarchy
and that was the, so that's it.
There was this sorta, oh.
So I was kind of an astral leap
in evolution from day one as an academic.
Then when I was living in Lexington,
the Lexington Board of
Education was approached
by the Citizens for
Balanced Teaching of Origins
in 1980 which was a community group
that wanted the Lexington
Board of Education
to include this new
science of creation science
to teach along with evolution,
and we'd be on the cutting
edge of science education.
And I had gotten interested
in the creationist movement
really as a graduate student,
'cause Jim Gavin who's,
you asked my mentors,
Jim Gavin was probably my main mentor
as shaping my view of anthropology.
Wonderful man, now deceased,
but Jim gave me some
creationist literature
when I was a first-year graduate student.
Man, I started collecting this stuff
'cause it was so interesting.
So when this big controversy
happened in Lexington,
I was the person on campus.
I was the person in the science faculty
who actually knew what
creation science was
and I had a whole box
of literature for it,
so I got interested in the creation
and evolution controversy pretty early.
- The skills and temperament
of a physical anthropologist
and the skills and
temperament of an activist,
somebody who's an advocate,
are somewhat different.
Did the second build on
the first, in other words,
or was there not that much
contradiction between the two?
- You know, I don't
know that I can go along
with your premise 'cause I don't know
that biological anthropologists differ
from any other academic, or even, frankly,
that academics differ that much
from accountants or
dentists or anybody else.
I think that, for example,
in the Lexington controversy,
which really took almost
two years to resolve,
and to cut to the chase,
the good guys won.
The Lexington District decided
not to require the teachers
to teach creation science.
But I worked with clergy,
I worked with civil liberty supporters
who were businessmen
and just normal people,
and of course, there were a
lot of us up on the campus
but they were from not just
the science disciplines
but also history and poli sci
and philosophy of science,
so there were a lot of us,
and those of us who do get interested
in this kind of activist
approach, and it is activism,
were trying to influence what
goes on in our communities.
That's activism.
Those of us who were interested,
I think, were different from
other people in the community,
'cause, A, we cared, (laughs)
but we cared for different reasons.
We cared for different reasons.
The clergy that I worked with were upset
at the thought that
somebody would be teaching
biblical literalism Monday through Friday
and they'd have to straighten
the kids out on the weekend,
on Saturday or Sunday in their churches,
'cause we don't believe
that in our denomination.
And so the Catholics
and the mainstream
Protestants were on my side.
The business community
didn't like the idea
of the schools teaching creationism
because kids would be raised
with an inferior education.
You don't deliberately teach
things that are not true.
The teachers didn't like
it because they felt
that they would be violating some
of their professional
standards by teaching nonsense
when their job is to teach good stuff.
So everybody had different reasons
for opposing the teaching of creationism,
but all of us, I think,
had to be willing to step up to the plate
and the most effective of us
had to have communication skills
that enabled us to do a good job,
to persuade the decision-makers
that our point of view
is the one that they should take.
And to some degree,
being a college professor
helps you on that
because frankly, we're all salesmen.
You sold political science
(laughs) when you taught.
I sold anthropology, in
the best sense of the term,
in that you are providing a set of ideas
to somebody that you want them to accept.
- The difference is that in your work,
and you were the founding director,
I wanna talk about your organization,
is that there's greater
diversity as you mobilize people.
There must be a lot of listening,
oh, is that what's bothering you,
then let me address that,
among different groups
and kind of learning that, hey,
the business community may be on our side
for reasons having to with
whatever the skills they need.
So talk a little about that,
'cause that's different than
what an academic is doing.
- Yeah, it is in some respects,
but in a way, well, I'm
trained as an anthropologist.
I'm a biological anthropologist
which really is a subfield of biology
and certainly the vast majority
of the research activity
that is done is indistinguishable
from what we're doing in a biology class
except that as an anthropologist,
we look at humans and primates
with an additional edge, as it were,
and that is in the cultural
and historical context.
When you study anthropology,
you study not just physical anthropology.
You study cultural anthropology
and archeology as well.
It's a very holistic kind of view
of what makes humans tick, and as such,
one of the things that you learn
is that if you're really going
to understand a point of view
you have to embed yourself, so to speak.
You have to spend the time
and you have to do a lot of listening.
It's kind of an ethnographic
approach, really,
and I think my being an anthropologist
did contribute a lot to the
orientation that I took.
Anthropologists also tend
to look in terms of systems,
and so I didn't know anything
about the public education
system in the city of Lexington.
I didn't have a kid in the school.
I didn't pay any attention at all to it,
but I learned that there's a difference
between the superintendent
and the Board of Education
and who reports to whom
and what does a department chairman do
and what's his relationship
to the superintendent
and who is actually the
decision-maker in all of this
and what's the responsibility of teachers.
I learned that K-12 teachers
don't have academic freedom
that we have at the university level.
It's a very, very different thing,
and actually there's very
good reasons for that.
So one of the things I had to do
when I just sort of stepped into this mess
in the Lexington, what we'd
call a flare-up at NCSE
when I was one of the leaders
and coping with this flare-up
is I had to figure out the
political system, (laughs)
but also what's going on
in the religious community
and I had to spend time with them.
I had some very good
informants in Rabbi Leffler
and the Unitarian minister then.
What are the forces within
the religious community
that could help to
support my point of view
versus those who oppose?
But also, and here's where the
real anthropology comes in,
why do they feel the way they do?
Why is there this strong
opposition to evolution?
People don't just do
things for no good reason.
What are the reasons that
people are so concerned
about their kids learning
evolution in the public schools?
And if you really understand that,
can you start a conversation
to try to figure out
how you can assuage those concerns?
Because they're very real
and they're very sincere.
- In establishing your organization,
the National Center for Science Education,
what was the biggest challenge
and what surprised you the
most as you were doing that?
- Well, the biggest
challenge for any non-profit,
we were talking about I
was a college professor
and then I became a
non-profit manager. (sighs)
I didn't know anything about
running a small business
and that's what a non-profit
is, it's a business.
A non-profit cannot be no-profit
because if you make no-profit,
you go out of business.
That's the nature of a business.
It's just that any profits you make
have to be plowed back into
your mission and so forth,
but you have to be in the black,
otherwise you fire your staff
and you take your books home.
So learning how to run a business
was actually not that hard.
The business community
might wince at that point,
but I had a PhD in science,
I can learn how to run a business.
It's not rocket science.
But fundraising, persuading
people to give money
to support the kinds of
things that NCSE does,
which is basically a lot of
what I learned in Lexington.
These problems of the
teaching of evolution
are local and state problems.
That's where education takes place.
We're very decentralized,
so what we did at NC, and do
and continue my successor,
what NCSE does is support
people in communities
who want to see that their kids
get good science education.
So we help them form coalitions
with like-minded people
to find out all of the interest
groups in their community
that might care about this issue
and how can you all work together.
We teach them how to write letters
to the editor, if they need to.
We teach them how to
make a good presentation
to a school board or
to a board of education
at the state level or a state legislature
because there are definitely
skills involved in that.
We give them the background in science
which they often do not know.
We give them the background
in theology many times,
which is also a very
important part of this.
We give them the legal backgrounds
because this is ultimately a matter
of church and state
separation, foundationally.
We talk about the pedagogical issues
and there's even philosophical,
philosophy of science issues as well,
so there's a lot of different areas
that nobody knows everything about
but NCSE can help local groups
to have the information that they need
to make the argument that
good science should be taught,
evolution should be taught,
nature of science should be taught.
Religiously-based groups
can be taught about
outside of science classes
but they should not be presented
as true science in a science class.
- What about the community of scientists?
You were a scientist.
- [Eugenie] Hopefully still am.
(both laughing)
- You were sounding the alarm
bell in the night in a way.
Was there difficulty there
in getting scientists out
of their labs and into the public space?
- Well, (sighs) we're talking,
I became director of NCSE
in the late '80s, 1986.
By the 1980s, I think there
had been enough creationism,
and of course intelligent
design was just starting
to ramp up in the late '80s,
that I think the science community
was having this wait a minute moment,
and of course most of my
staff were from the science.
I'm a scientist, most of
my staff were from science,
and I think all of us had connections
with different scientist disciplines
and we found scientists very responsive.
Now, not 100% but that's
gonna be the case any time,
but one of the sources that we tapped
was the associations of science,
the American Association for
the Advancement of Science,
the National Academy of Sciences
which is not really an association but,
GSA, Geological Society of America,
of course the Physical Anthropologists.
They were strongly behind us.
The various American Institute
for Biological Sciences.
There were a lot of
scientist organizations
that NCSE dealt with and
I would be asked to speak
at their meetings and I would
speak with their officers
and help explain why this is a problem
and why we needed scientists to help
and what scientists could do to help,
and we established networks of scientists.
So scientists and teachers
were actually our core constituencies.
In fact, back in the
late '70s and early '80s,
early '80s certainly, when
NCSE was just getting started,
it was scientists and teachers
who really put this organization together.
- Help us understand
the way scientists think
and the way creationists,
let's just create that broad category.
What's the difference
in the way they think
and then the hurdle in getting
them to talk to each other
or at least understand each
other if not talk to each other?
- I think the first thing
is to make a distinction.
You said scientists and creationists,
and that tends to be two separate sets.
Although some creationists
are trained in science,
they're pretty much outside
of the scientific mainstream.
That's very different from
saying that there are two sets,
scientists and religious people.
That's not the same thing
because many religious
people are scientists.
Many scientists are religious people.
Many theologians are really
interested in science
and that's part of their theology.
So it's not a distinction
between science and religion
so much as it is a distinction
between scientifically-oriented
people and everybody else.
And I think this is really
what you're getting to
but I wanted to be sure
to make that distinction
because I'm not talking
about all religious people
when I'm talking about creationists.
The difference between creationists
and real scientists, if you will,
is that creationists
start with a conclusion.
They have the revealed truth of the Bible
and they believe that this
trumps all empirical evidence.
If there's a difference between
what their interpretation
of the Bible says and
what you see in nature,
well, you just must not be
interpreting nature correctly.
And the way they interpret the Bible,
the traditional young Earth creationists,
the Bible is interpreted
as requiring a young Earth
of only thousands of years old, 6,000.
The more radical will go
all the way up to 10,000,
but certainly not billions,
not anywhere near that.
The Bible requires, in
their interpretation,
the special creation
of the whole universe,
so galaxies and stars and Earth
are all specially created.
God just went, let there be,
and animals and plants and human beings
are specially created
according to special kinds.
You can have evolution within the kind,
so you can have a dog kind
and you can have the evolution
of wolves and foxes and domestic dogs,
but that's still the kind.
The kind is different.
It was a created kind
and you don't get dogs
and bears having a common ancestor.
That's just not allowed whatsoever.
So they start with a conclusion,
this is the way the world is,
and then they basically look
through the scientific information
to try to find the stuff that supports it.
Now, any scientist
who's got an explanation
is gonna look for
corroborating information.
We're all gonna look for the stuff
that supports our point of view,
but if you're a real
scientist, you go an extra step
and you say, if I'm
wrong, what should I find?
And then you have to look for that.
And this is the big difference
between creationists and real scientists.
They're ignoring any of the information
that refutes their point of view.
- The non-scientists?
- Non-scientists, yeah.
- Yeah.
- The creationists have the truth.
They cherry-pick the
data that supports them
and ignore or somehow
explain away any data
that would refute their point of view
of special creation, a
young Earth, et cetera.
- Scientists are constantly,
as you point out in your book,
rethinking their theories
based on the empirical evidence
and in a way, the very rigor
and protocol of science
makes their conclusions
potentially vulnerable
in the public sphere,
and I gather from your discussion
of the history of the creationists
is that as they move
toward trying to come up
with a scientific explanation of creation
that they build on a platform
that attacks the fact
that scientists are changing their mind.
Talk a little about that,
but the scientists are changing their mind
based on empirical evidence.
They're revising their thinking.
- Yeah, science is an
open-ended way of knowing.
It's an epistemology that
allows you to change your mind.
It's a feature, not a bug, okay? (laughs)
But that doesn't mean that
everything in science changes
and I think that's an initial idea
that I think people may not understand.
There are a core set of explanations
that have just been tested so much
that we're not gonna change them, okay.
Matter is composed of atoms.
The Earth goes around the sun.
Geocentrism is here to stay.
Laws of thermodynamics, living
things have common ancestors.
There's a lot of core ideas
that just aren't gonna change.
There's a lot of ideas
that are frontier ideas
and this is where scientists are working.
Some of them are gonna
work and go into the core.
Some of them are not gonna work
and we abandon them and
that's fine, but not every,
science is open-ended but it's reliable,
and that's important.
That's an important distinction to have.
Now, one of the problems
that creationists have
which you mentioned is
that they are not flexible
in changing their explanations.
New evidence is not gonna make them
alter their point of view.
They will explain it
away, they will ignore it,
they will in some other way discredit it
because they already have
the true explanation.
But this actually gets back
to some very old traditions
within Christianity,
well, without getting into too much detail
in that although it's
an interesting topic,
the creationists view science
as producing truth but
the truth has to accord
with what they already believe is true
and it is a weakness when
you change your explanation.
So they will criticize
evolution by saying, well,
last year you said that
the big Australopithecines
and the little Australopithecines
were two separate species
and now you're saying the same species.
You guys are always changing
your mind about evolution.
It's all a bunch of whole cloth.
So changing your mind is a
structural weakness to them,
whereas to us, it's a feature, not a bug.
It's how we get closer to
an accurate explanation
of how the world works.
- The media, in a way,
in its effort to be fair, becomes unfair
in the sense that I'm now thinking about
news items on nutrition,
what's good for you to eat.
Is coffee good for you
or is it bad for you?
Is wine good for you?
And part of this is
they're not understanding
what you just described about science.
There's constant revision
so that the structure
there would seem to help
in the process of delegitimating science,
not in reality, not in
science at its core,
but what its adversaries
are saying against it.
- You know, it's a double-edged sword.
We want the media to cover science
because that way the public
learns more about science.
The public is very interested in science
and wants to know more about science,
and of course, the more public
understands about science,
the more likely they are to support it
and basically the public
does support science.
I'm happy to say they think
more money should be spent
on scientific research,
but simultaneously,
so it's really great
that the press covers new
scientific developments
but there's a lot of
stuff that's out there
on that frontier, outside of that core.
There's a lot of stuff
that's still pretty iffy.
We're still figuring it out.
What's the effect of
caffeine on heart disease?
What's the effect of caffeine
on this kind of heart disease
versus that kinda heart?
We don't really know yet,
and so a study will come out saying A
and the press will report it.
A study will come out six
months later saying B,
the press will report it.
We want the press to report it,
but the public can get
confused because it seems like
these scientists are
always changing their mind
like the creationists say.
I think where the press could
help would be to make sure
that they're communicating
the tentativeness of science.
Study A has just been produced
and it has this conclusion.
Generally speaking, if you
interview the scientists
who wrote the paper, paper A of topic A,
they will tell you, well,
these are preliminary findings.
We think they're strong but
more work needs to be done.
That often doesn't get
communicated to the public
and there's a structural
problem here, frankly,
because most of us in our daily
lives, we do like certainty.
Uncertainty is unsettling
in some respects.
Is the bus gonna come on time or not?
There's a lot of little and big things
that are uncertain in our lives,
but any scientist has
to be very comfortable
with saying I don't know yet,
and I would always encourage
them to add the yet,
because again, in terms of communicating
with the public about science,
the public will pick up the
idea that if you don't know yet,
that means you might know in the future.
If you just say it's a mystery,
people will think, oh, it's
unsolvable, which is different.
So I don't know yet is something
that scientists say all the time
and we feel comfortable with.
Being comfortable with
uncertainty is a distinction
that you find more among
scientists than the general public.
They get much more upset
with paper A saying
caffeine affects heart
disease X in this way
and then somebody coming up six
months later and saying, no,
caffeine does not affect
heart disease X in that way.
Well, who knows?
We don't know yet.
We just need to help
people understand that yet.
- In your book, you have a
quote from Saint Augustine
which I thought was very interesting.
This is what Augustine
wrote, Saint Augustine.
If they find a Christian mistaken
in a field which they know
well, that is the people,
and hearing him maintaining
his foolish opinions
about the scriptures,
how then are they going to
believe those scriptures
in matters concerning the
resurrection of the dead,
the hope of eternal life
and the kingdom of heaven,
how indeed when they
think their pages are full
of falsehoods on facts which
they themselves have learned
from experience in the light of reason?
So he's really warning the
advocates of Christianity
that you can't touch people's,
what they know from everyday experience.
- What he's saying there
is don't interpret the Bible literally.
And this was Augustine,
that was a long time ago.
Biblical literalism is a
relatively recent development
in Christian theology.
I think that's also a
very well-kept secret
in this whole controversy,
that interpreting the Bible
as six 24-hour days is fairly recent.
There's a little background radiation
all through Christian history,
but most Christian
theologians since Augustine
have not been biblically literalist.
Biblical literalism
came about as a product
of the fundamentalist movement
which was an early 20th century movement.
This was not a movement that is back
in the 800s or something like that.
This is a movement to refine
Protestant Christianity
that came about in the 19 teens and 1920s.
So it's a pretty recent,
as Christianity's been
around for a long time.
It's a pretty recent movement,
and it's been very
popular in North America
but it's not especially popular in Europe
and in some other parts of the world.
- It's funny, as you're speaking,
what comes to my mind is the literalists
interpreting the Constitution.
(Eugenie laughing)
- [Eugenie] You're a
political scientist, are you?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- There's a study--
- Comes by it naturally.
- You in your book which
I heartily recommend,
I should show it, Evolution
Versus Creationism.
- Second edition. (laughs)
- Second edition published by UC Press.
You look at the Scopes Trial.
You go through that history
'cause history is this bigger picture
which you're very attuned
to, and to summarize briefly,
there were three changes that occurred
in the environment at the time of Scopes.
One was the rise of fundamentalism
which you just discussed.
The second thing was the
importance of secondary education.
The numbers were really increasing there
and the third factor is
escaping me right now
but there was another historical factor--
- [Eugenie] Oh, well, World War One.
- Yeah, World War One, that's right,
and the whole discrediting
of the survival of the fittest notion.
So this was a classic battle
which was won indirectly
by the evolutionists, but
then in the aftermath of that,
evolution wasn't put in
the texts, so therefore--
- In fact it was taken out of the texts.
- Texts, yeah.
- There was more evolution before Scopes,
more evolution in
textbooks in the curriculum
before Scopes than after.
- And so ironically the court victory
didn't have the positive repercussions
but then evolution in this
conflict with the creationists
comes back when we have the
Space Race in the 1950s.
The importance of what
you're saying here is
the broader environment,
the social context,
the political history is very important
for the ups and downs of this controversy.
- Yeah, absolutely, that
summarizes the history very nicely.
Anti-evolutionism has been a sine wave.
It's waxed and waned over time. (sighs)
Like I was saying a moment ago,
before the Scopes Trial at
the turn of the century,
you can find textbooks
that talk about this relatively new idea.
It's only 50, 60 years
old from Charles Darwin
that living things have common ancestors
and here's this explanation
of natural selection
for how it works, and this
is new science and so forth,
and it was assumed in the textbooks.
When more and more kids
started going to school,
the number of kids in secondary school,
generally speaking at
the turn of the century
if you got to eighth grade
you were well-educated and that was it.
But with high school
becoming much more common,
and urbanization, more
people were being exposed
to these textbooks and
with the creationist,
excuse me, with the
fundamentalist movement
and the biblical literalist
kind of theology being pushed,
there was a conflict, so
evolution was taken out
of the textbooks again and
stayed out until the 1960s
when, because of the scare
of the Russians getting to space first,
the National Science Foundation
started funding science education
including the publication
of textbooks written
by scientists in biology, geology,
physics, and earth science,
and the biology textbooks,
because they were written
by practicing university scientists
and master teachers, included evolution.
So evolution got into the curriculum again
which generated opposition
from the creationists
'cause they didn't have to worry
between about 1930 and about 1965.
They didn't have to worry
about evolution being taught
'cause it wasn't being taught,
but once it started being taught,
again, that ramped up the
anti-evolution movement.
And eventually the equal-time laws
of the late '70s started being proposed
where you had to balance evolution
by the teaching of creation
science which they had invented.
And so evolution started going
out of the textbooks again.
We fought to put it back in in the '80s
and that plus some court decisions
generated the intelligent
design movement, so, you know,
if it's not one damn thing,
it's another. (laughs)
- You also, in your book,
have an interesting discussion
of essentially myth, and of the notion,
and myth being the ideas that are central
to a society or a nation, and in a way,
some of the myths come
from the way people live,
the social experience of their lives,
and you pointed out that the school,
the history of the schools being
a decentralized enterprise,
you talked about, as are the churches.
And so you got local control,
which means that all the battles
are often in a decentralized area,
as you discussed in your
first awakening to this.
It seems, so this is what
I wanna to pose to you,
which is the progressive
agenda really often comes
from a center at the national level,
whereas then the fight
emerges with the local level,
which embraces some of the non-scientific
ways of looking at things.
Talk a little about that, is that unfair?
- Well, (sighs)
it's a push me pull you kinda thing,
yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Education is highly decentralized.
Decisions about what gets taught,
who's gonna teach, how
much you're gonna pay,
those are all local decisions.
To some degree in the last 20 years,
the focus has shifted a
little bit more to the state
partly for funding reasons.
If the state is gonna give
money to the local districts,
they can tie strings to it
so there may be some curricular pressures
on local districts, but really,
a local district can decide
to thumb its nose at the state
and teach any damn thing it wants,
within constitutional (laughs) reason.
You can't teach the violent
overthrow of the government.
That's treason, so they're
not gonna teach that.
But the decentralization
is really important
in American education, and so as a result,
when evolution creeps
back into the textbooks
and people on the local level
notice, this tends to support
national anti-evolutionist organizations.
The Institute for Creation Research
and later Answers in
Genesis and a whole raft
of small anti-evolutionist organizations
have sprung up at different times.
The IC are being the most
important in terms of my work,
and they are very influential
'cause they're sort of
our evil twin. (laughs)
Somebody's gonna quote
me on that, I know it,
but they provide information
for their grassroots people
just like NCSE provides information
for grassroots people on
our side of this issue
to better persuade decision-makers
at the local and state level.
- We can't say they're evil.
- No, yeah.
- They're just the opposite
side, yeah, okay, we'll just, yeah, yeah.
- It's a joke about the evil twin
'cause that's a cultural motif, but yeah.
But it's like the black and the white,
it's like the yin and yang.
The national organizations
provide information
to the grassroots but
if it doesn't get done
at the grassroots, it doesn't get done.
People always ask me, oh,
with the new administration,
or now that that administration is gone,
it's gonna be easier,
it's gonna be harder.
The federal government has hardly anything
to do with curriculum,
and whether evolution is taught
or not is a curricular issue
and curriculum is determined
at the state and local level,
so regardless of what somebody
in a given administration
believes about creationism,
they're not gonna be able
to do a heck of a lot
to see that when the
classroom door gets shut
in Mrs. Brown's classroom,
she's gonna pull out the
creation science materials.
There also has been a legal
history of the battles
between evolution and anti-evolution for,
well, let's see now, for almost 100 years.
That is very relevant to this
whole controversy as well.
But just in terms of
the national grassroots,
decentralization, versus local control,
it's a combination of factors.
But the NCSE would not have
been able to accomplish
as much as it's accomplished
over the years of our existence
if it hadn't been for people
at the grassroots willing
to take the time and spend the energy
and tremendous amount of
effort in trying to see
that good science gets
taught in their schools.
- As we see in the world today,
let's talk about today
and we see a movement
across the globe toward
authoritarianism in various degrees.
Some might even speculate
about that movement here
in the United States.
And authoritarian demagogic leaders
basically often built their
platform on fear, anxiety,
untruths, shall we call them, if not lies.
Do you see this as a more
precarious environment
as things evolve in this direction
in terms of the battles you're fighting?
Well, just as a citizen,
I'm very concerned with
these kinds of pressures.
It is something that I
think all citizens ought
to be concerned about.
In terms specifically of the
creation and evolution issue
I think it's less closely related
simply because of the
grassroots orientation
and the fact that it is
not a constant thing.
Where you find controversies arising
over the teaching of
evolution occur at intervals,
every six or seven or however many years
in a given state or district.
The science curriculum will be examined
and the next year they'll
look at the math curriculum
and the year after that they'll look
at the English language arts,
but at regular five to
seven years, generally,
they'll take a look at
the science curriculum
and that's when
anti-evolutionism may appear.
Right now as we're talking,
there's a problem in the state of Arizona
over the adoption of
state evolution standards
where the Board of Education
has tinkered around
with the coverage of
climate change and evolution
in a way that is not good,
and so citizens are
pushing back against that.
But you talked about anxieties.
I think there are anxieties
that people have but they're,
fascism functions much better
the more diffused the anxieties are.
If you are very precise
about your anxieties,
you can be disproved,
so it's always better to have
just sort of a general haze
of anxiety out there and
you're gonna be more successful
at imposing your undemocratic views.
I don't think the creationism issue
fits into that quite as well.
It may be a secondary component
if there is an upsurge
of more conservative
forms of Christianity,
but conservative Christianity
is not monolithic
in terms of the kinds of political views
that you were talking about.
There are quite a few green Christians,
environmentally-oriented Christians
who really believe in stewardship theology
and it's their job to
reduce the amount of carbon.
Climate change is a big problem.
We have to do this, that, and the other.
There are a lot of
social justice Christians
who are very concerned about
things like immigration
because we are our brother's keeper.
They have biblical and
theological reasons for
resisting some of the
anti-immigration statutes
and so forth that may be on the way.
So even if conservative
religious views are
encouraged by those who
are perhaps not reflecting
what I would consider
the best American values,
it doesn't mean that that is
going to necessarily result
in an increase in anti-evolutionism
which is a long-winded answer
to your question.
- But in a way
you're suggesting that it's not inevitable
that there's a spillover
from the evolution debate
to the climate change debate.
In other words, they're different actors
but the one variable here is inequality,
economic inequality, and
the funding of opposition,
for example, to climate change.
Is that something we need to worry about
or is it really a strategy,
what you need is a strategy
of not lumping these
things together if you--
- I think they're independent enough.
There's a small overlap but it's focusing
on that smallish overlap
is probably not gonna be
the best use of resources.
- Even though climate change deniers
are anti-science in a way?
- I don't think that they
would consider themselves that.
- [Harry] I see.
- I think that the people who'd, okay,
they're not anti-science generically.
They may be anti the
research done in this field
and I've been talking to scientists
on campus the last couple
of days during my visit
which is always a very pleasant
part of a visit like this
and I was talking to one professor.
He was saying, well, you know,
the evolution issue is
much more straightforward
than the climate change issue
in that evolution has just been so
strongly established.
Living things have common ancestors.
That is the only explanation
that explains biology
as we know it today, and we know a lot
about the mechanisms and
genetics and so forth.
With climate change, there are some things
that we are absolutely positive about.
There are core ideas of
climate change as well.
CO2 and methane are warming
gases, we know that.
We know that they have increased.
The inference is very
clear that the increase
in warming gases has
increased the temperature
of the planet very rapidly
over this short period of time.
Modeling is something that is
extraordinarily complicated
and that scientists will disagree on,
and scientific disagreement
is the bread and butter of science.
There's nothing wrong with that,
and scientists will sometimes
have exceedingly vigorous conversations
and arguments about who's right,
and eventually a consensus
is going to emerge
but when you're saying this model shows
that in 15 years the ocean is
going to be raised three feet
and somebody else says, okay,
but your model is wrong in
here, here, and here and here,
and my model shows that the
ocean will be up six feet.
That is likely a legitimate
scientific controversy.
For we laymen, in terms of the
climate change controversy,
the important thing is, dang,
the ocean's really gonna be raising a lot.
We gotta do something about this.
Splitting hairs over
whether it's three feet
or six feet may not be the
big worry we should have,
but people who are against the idea
of anthropogenic climate change
are usually attacking that kind of thing
rather than the basic
physics behind warming gases
and their effect on the planet.
- Well, Eugenie, I wanna
thank you very much
for coming to Berkeley
as the Hitchcock Lecture
and taking time in that
visit to be on our program
and I would like to show your book again,
Evolution Versus Creationism,
and it's quite a good
read for somebody wanting
to learn more about that debate
which you've played
such an active part in.
Thank you very much
for being here with us,
thank you.
- Thank you for inviting me.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(pulsating electronic music)